Білборди на вулицях Харкова яскраво свідчать про те, хто претендує на лідерство
у передвиборчих перегонах на посаду мера: виконувач обов’язків міського голови Ігор Терехов
та ексмер і ексгубернатор Михайло Добкін. За традицією, сформованою ще померлим Геннадієм Кернесом,
який "не пускав" на білборди в місті нікого, окрім себе, тепер таку традицію
перейняв його колишній заступник Ігор Терехов, який виконує повноваження мера Харкова
після смерті Кернеса. Плакатів Михайла Добкіна - помітно менше.
А решти восьми кандидатів узагалі майже не видно.
На тлі двобою "Терехов проти Добкіна" шанси в них і так нульові.
Головна боротьба за крісло мера ведеться не на білбордах міста і навіть
не на місцевих телеканалах, куди здебільшого має доступ лише кандидат від влади Ігор Терехов.
На повну працюють канали кандидатів у соцмережах, зокрема активно
розкручуються всілякі компромати. А також ведеться масова агітація
харків’ян просто біля їхніх будинків.
Як тільки на Харків опускаються сутінки, кандидати починають полювати на виборців.
Вони обирають вечірні години, бо так більше шансів застати мешканців вдома
після робочого дня. Особливо кандидати полюбляють робити "ходки"
в житлові масиви на околицях міста. Туди, куди раніше, мабуть, навіть нога
самого Кернеса не ступала, який вкрай полюбляв такий формат спілкування з виборцями.
Гартованим залізом випалимо з Харкова наркотики!
Закрити всі "наливайки"!
Безпеку будемо самі організовувати. Я буду створювати муніципальну систему охорони.
Заборонимо торгівлю алкоголем з 10-тої вечора до 10-тої ранку!
Колись головні претенденти на посаду міського голови працювали майже в одній команді.
Поряд або з Кернесом. А тепер борються, власне, насамперед за його електорат,
який був настільки вірний Кернесу, що голосував за "Гепу", навіть коли той перебував
у лікарні в Німеччині. А це - 61% харків'ян. Нині ж для Добкіна та Терехова
Кернес радше не об'єднавча ланка, а яблуко розбрату. Дружби вже давно немає.
Хоча, як розповів DW сам Добкін, на початку передвиборчої кампанії
представники кандидатів говорили про можливість об’єднатися.
Щоправда, у штабі Терехова цю інформацію DW не підтвердили.
Я був готовий працювати з ним, враховуючи його інтереси як секретаря міськради.
Але там амбіції перейшли усі точки неповернення. Я з ним ніколи не працював.
Навпаки, коли я працював в місті, він працював у Арсена Борисовича Авакова.
Але це був вибір Гени, Геннадія Адольфовича. Я ставився до цього як до належного.
Але придивившись, я згодом зрозумів, що, напевно, він був добрим професійним заступником.
Але на перше обличчя Харкова він сьогодні не тягне, бо Харків - це не лише дахи,
підвали, прибирання листя і прибирання снігу взимку.
Терехов у боргу не залишився.
Геннадій Адольфович називав Добкіна, особливо в останні роки свого життя,
"листом, забутим на пошті". Тому можу вам сказати, що між Добкіним та Кернесом
останні кілька років були такі стосунки, що він його на поріг не пускав.
Терехов позиціонує себе великим господарником, наслідувачем міських проєктів,
започаткованих Кернесом. Добкін б'є на те, що він вже був мером і губернатором і знає,
як керувати містом. Обидва кандидати намагаються назбирати собі виборчі бонуси,
обіцяючи вирішення одних і тих же проблем харків'ян: вчасне та якісне опалення,
перебої з гарячою та холодною водою, ремонти у житлових будинках,
якісна медицина тощо. Щоправда, самі кандидати не бачать схожості між собою.
Місто Харків динамічно розвивається та розвиватиметься. Нова система транспорту,
нові автобуси, які, до речі, збиратимуться в Харкові.
Це нові виробництва, це новий ІТ-кластер.
Тобто багатовекторний розвиток міста Харкова, колосальні інфраструктурні проєкти,
створення нових робочих місць, насичення бюджету, модернізація теплових мереж.
І друге - це стратегія розвитку міста Харків без околиць.
Всі рішення глобальні для міста я прийматиму сам.
Попередньо зваживши всі за і проти і спираючись на моє розуміння точки зору харків'ян.
Не сумніваюся, що мій візаві ухвалюватиме рішення, радячись з декількома людьми,
які сьогодні беруть активну участь у тому, щоб його обрали мером.
І ці люди до Харкова не мають жодної прив'язки, вони тут не мешкають.
Обидва кандидати почали боротьбу за крісло мера ще навесні, одразу після того,
як Верховна Рада ухвалила рішення про призначення виборів мера на 31 жовтня.
З того часу Харків роздирає війна компроматів. Терехову приписують,
що він нібито перейняв повноваження Кернеса незаконно. Обговорюють і те,
кому дісталася так звана чорна каса ексмера. Терехова звинувачують в тому,
що його агітаційні заходи проходили без дотримання карантинних обмежень
і сприяли поширенню коронавіруса в Харкові.
А Добкіну нагадують про те, як він з Кернесом свого часу "роздерибанили"
землі в Харкові, як сумнівно використовували бюджетні гроші,
як придушували громадські протести, опозицію. Згадують і його прихильність до Януковича,
і те, що він з Кернесом могли бути причетними до спроби сепаратистів
у 14-тому році віддати Харків у руки Росії.
Головне те, що Добкін хотів привести до Харкова війну.
А ми з Геннадієм Адольфовичем відстояли. І сьогодні в нашому місті немає війни.
Я маю на увазі ті події, які тоді відбувалися. Я все сказав, так.
Добкін заперечує, що хотів перетворити Харків у так звану "ХНР".
Харків уникнув долі, при якій про місто можна було говорити в умовному способі.
Харків сьогодні є частиною України. Тут мирне небо. Хоча тут люди стикаються
з колосальними проблемами. Але принаймні вони не мають глобальної проблеми.
Вони не бояться бомбардувань.
Через 7 років після тих подій для харків'ян, схоже, загрози проросійського реваншу більше не існує.
Сепаратисти? Я не розумію. Для мене ці поняття не існують. Я харків'янин.
Та ні! Я гадаю, що ніхто це не ризикне.
Тим паче, що місто Харків - це ж не область, не Валки, не Богодухів, не Люботин.
Це люди, які вже перевірені.
Ми ж один з одним спілкуємося в інтернеті, в гості їздимо і за кордоном
ми зустрічаємося як нормальні люди. А ось вся ця політика нас не має
стосуватися абсолютно. Тим не менше ми від неї страждаємо.
Я вважаю, що просто треба жити. Кожен має займатися своєю справою і не лізти в чужий город.
Та ми живемо в Україні! Яка Росія? Не буде вже жодного повтору 14-го року!
Все буде гаразд!
Нам не треба 14-го року.
Цікаво, що обидва кандидати хочуть дружити з Росією. І ось як це пояснюють.
Як я розумію, Україна має низку певних проблем, і нам потрібно чітко визначитися,
як ми рухаємося, за яким курсом.
На мій погляд, ми маємо бути країною, яка дружить з Росією.
І ми маємо бути європейською країною, яка дружить з ЄС та Америкою.
Я за відновлення відносин з усіма державами, зокрема і з РФ.
Я загалом пацифіст і вважаю, що без торгівлі з Росією наші підприємства не виживуть.
Але торгівля та економічні відносини не означає, що до Харкова
прийде інша влада - під чужими прапорами, з чужим гімном.
Можна жити і нормально розвиватися, зокрема економічно, торгуючи
та працюючи з усіма. Ми ж зрештою закопали сокиру ворожнечі з ФРН.
Обидва кандидати в мери висловлюються проти війни і за те, що Росія має
повернути Україні захоплені території. Заяви про відновлення стосунків з РФ
і спілкування російською навіть попри закон, який зобов’язує
чиновників розмовляти українською, продиктовані тим, що головний електорат Харкова
- це російськомовні люди, які все ще ностальгують за радянськими часами,
коли вся промисловість Харкова працювала на РФ, каже голова
місцевого комітету виборців України Михайло Камчатний.
Я бачу навпаки, що кандидати дистанціювалися від Росії і тримають
таку нейтральну проукраїнську політику. Обидва. Я не бачу... Це ж політика.
Зараз не модно бути проросійським. Розумієте. Політики підлаштовуються під це.
Згідно із соцопитуваннями, у представників інших політичних сил шанси
перемогти у Харкові нульові. Партія Зеленського навіть не виставила свого кандидата.
Чинному виконувачу обов’язків міського голови нині прогнозують більше
шансів на перемогу. У штабі Добкіна скаржаться на надмірне
використання адмінресурсу Тереховим. Приміром, виборцям у дворі
роздають безкоштовні квитки в зоопарк, який реконструювали
в часи Кернеса і який став однією з "фішок" кампанії Терехова.
Але якихось серйозних порушень виборчого законодавства в Харкові
поки не фіксували.
Гречкосіїв зафіксовано не було. В основному були баталії й обливання брудом у соцмережах.
Це ми чітко виділяємо.
Саме соціальні мережі стали майданчиком, де вся компанія розгорталася.
Але виборчий кодекс ніяк не регулює соцмережі. Це великий майданчик для маневрів.
Щоправда, майданчик для маневрів нині обмежений пандемією.
Наразі в Харкові спостерігають стрімке зростання інфікувань коронавірусом,
лікарні переповнені. Але жорсткі обмежувальні заходи в транспорті,
в громадських місцях досі не запроваджені.
І вибори відбудуться в нормальному режимі.
Які пісні Харків співатиме після 31 жовтня, залежить від того, чи набере
один з кандидатів 50 відсотків плюс 1 голос.
Якщо ні - через три тижні відбудеться другий тур.